we have the story from the wall street
journal
biden draws criticism after raising
prospect of illegitimate 2022 election
white house says president wasn't
casting doubt on midterm results let's
let's not waste time joe biden was asked
about not getting through two bills
which would overhaul the us election
system he then said that he thinks in
the election in november would be
illegitimate which is an insane thing to
say because if these bills have not been
voted in now then what's he saying about
the 2020 election well jenn sackey comes
out and she goes let me be clear he
wasn't saying that the election would be
illegitimate he's saying what trump did
blah blah blah because then kamala
harris comes out and she goes hold on
there let me finish the election will be
and then she basically backed up
joe biden
joe biden and kamala harris have pushed
the idea that the election will not be
free and fair because they did not get
through their complete voter overhaul
wow it's like a child screaming when
they don't get a candy bar how about
this but he's the president how how yes
absolutely you want and you want to talk
about trump arguing about voter fraud
and stuff too i'm not going to play
these games you can't come out and ban
on youtube discussion of donald trump's
opinions and then not so so hold on
there a minute youtube i certainly hope
you start enforcing this against all of
the biden supporters who are going to be
saying this stupid nonsense so they say
they don't want you to say that certain
elections in the past have have been
rigged or whatever that's kind of part
of youtube's events but this is what
about your life future of elections is
okay to say hey maybe
demoralizing to say that stuff though
for the president to be like this
election's not going to be any good
upcoming people won't vote if you say
that dude so don't say that i agree and
uh
i as well as many others have been
critical of trump and many trump
supporters for telling people
that there's effectively you know by
pushing the fraud narrative
it tells people not to bother and then
you see what happens in georgia when the
democrats end up winning two seats they
should not have won but there were
people outside who are saying there's no
point why bother and it's like you need
to go vote man more importantly you need
to vote in the primaries you got to vote
in all your local elections and then you
got to make sure the establishment
uniparty types are removed and this is
our opportunity
i have a feeling come you know next uh
december i'm going to be very very
disappointed
but you know for the time being i'm
going to be like guys primary everyone
democrat republican primary amal and if
you don't like any of that vote mises
caucus dude i think they see what's
coming right they see that the midterms
are going to be a total washout because
people are not happy with biden's
policies his approval rating is in the
tanks so they know the numbers they have
this internal data so they're trying to
see this narrative now and they're gonna
be talking about this and pushing it for
the next year so that when it happens
they can pull their whole russiagate
nonsense again well this the election
was stolen somebody did something and
they might they might point a gap by the
way because we have you know almost 100
candidates in the 2022 race on our site
that are organizing raising money
building communities etc and i think
we're going to be an underdog for this
for this race and we may get blamed for
the red wave that is coming i have never
said
donald trump won the 2020 2022 election
i have said in 2020 like in may and
october people are bringing this up that
trump was right about certain issues
pertaining to fraud but that was before
an election took place and there was
like cnn reporting on fraud and stuff
but not widespread fraud i have no
problem
arguing with people like steve bannon
having those debates and now we're at a
point where the democrats
pulling a complete 180 and doing
everything they complained republicans
were doing and that's why i'm just like
you can't gaslight me
you can have this conversation i can
look into this i can ask for evidence
but then when you come out and try and
make you think i'm stupid enough to
believe that after a year or longer of
you saying all of these things about
trump then you start saying them sorry
it literally can't work you must believe
these people are dumb as a box of rocks
unfortunately some people are very dumb
but the narrative is not going to work
anymore this is this is also going to be
a red pill moment for a lot of people
they're gonna be like wait a minute
aren't the democrats the ones claiming
trump was lying about fraud and then
trump claimed he won and now they're
already starting to push that same exact
narrative yes because they're liars
i think people are gonna wake up to this
and be like hey maybe the media is lying
to me i hope more people do to be honest
i got i feel like the uh
the brain of the american country got it
infected by like a parasite when the
federal reserves performed their coup in
1913 and now it's like i love i'm
looking at it like it's my wife who has
a parasite in her brain and i'm like i
love you you are everything to me but
it's not her anymore it's something else
now but i still love the corporeal form
what am i supposed to do i want to
extract the parasite i want to reduce
the federal reserve and and create a new
economy the best way to do that is by
getting into things like bitcoin that
and that is why they're freaking out you
see them starting to see this narrative
right now hillary's coming out even
trump has come out against bitcoin right
why is that right so people should start
looking into that because the way you
know i was talking about this before we
started the show bitcoin is free speech
money bitcoin is the only reason that
gab still exists right now because in
2019 when we got banned from everything
payment processors paypal everything we
were still able to accept bitcoin we
didn't need permission from any bank we
didn't need permission from any
corporation or any government to do that
that is how we take down the federal
reserve that woman is a succubus ian and
[Laughter]
be careful watch out she's going to take
everything from you including all of
your money but she leave you and
dedicated forever okay i'm sorry she
still represents a great idea that
should be protected at all costs but to
go on this kind of uh area when it comes
to cryptocurrencies i think this is why
countries like venezuela and russia have
been talking about developing their own
cryptocurrencies the us federal reserve
is also hinting that they may just
create fed coin but just like anything
it's a technology just like the internet
it could be used for good it could be
used for bad and you guys were helped by
julian assange was helped by it when he
was de-banked major banking institutions
visa mastercard attacked julian assange
and wikileaks because the cia ordered
them to do so they took down all of his
accounts and he was only able to raise
money with bitcoin which made him a
multi-millionaire so you know everything
has a karmic way of working out in the
world and i think whether it's it's a
psyop or not a psy up cryptocurrency
does represent a possibility of freeing
people just like the internet did we
just have to hope it doesn't get
corrupted it is like the monetary
version of a free speech network correct
it is people's ability to bypass the
establishment their controls their
narratives what i love most about
bitcoin is the stories about really
weird and gross people who became
millionaires and billionaires it's just
like the dude in 2011 who was like i
need a i need a decentralized and you
know secret currency to use for what
reason i wonder and now they're rich
dude i had a guy sleeping on my couch
who's a billionaire right now i'm not
even joking with a bee and he was a bum
he was eating my macaroni and cheese
like microwavable and and
and then i shouts out to you i have i
i'm still shocked i don't know exactly
what i'm talking about the dude was a
like he i was just like dude you know
like i let
back in the day you know if someone
needed to stay somewhere i was like yeah
i stay at my place this dude was
overstaying his welcome like a mother he
was i was like dude you know maybe you
could go stay at someone else's back
sounds like i don't want that i don't
want to have interest bro remember times
10. you didn't pay me back remember when
max kaiser i think it was gave alex
jones 10 000 bitcoin i was there
you know they say bitcoin is
decentralized but
if you're at the top of it looking down
at the blockchain you're basically
looking at a centralized system of nodes
so it's really centralized not
necessarily no no they're at this point
you know over this many years right it
has become so decentralized and that is
that is why you know china has tried to
overtake it with the mining and stuff
and they haven't been successful right
every attempt to take down bitcoin every
time there's an article that comes out
bitcoin is dead oh it's tanking now it's
dead this time there's actually a
website that tracks this it's been like
hundreds of times over the past 13 years
or whatever it is that the reason that i
trust bitcoin so much is not only
because it saved my own business but
also because no central authority
controls it there's not one government
and by the way there are countries now
entire countries that are adopting
bitcoin which is really telling and when
i see the establishment you know both
the left and the right coming out and
attacking it that's when i know that it
is the real deal um you know it is
absolutely decentralized and it is
absolutely the only one that is
decentralized i'm a bitcoin maximalist
myself i believe that bitcoin is the
thing that is going to end these things
like the central bankers the federal
reserve all these things i think it's a
matter of time yeah el salvador uh
implemented it right they're kind of
national currency and the world bank and
the imf started attacking them because
of it yes oh yeah and now they're doing
financially you know better than they
were before they're allowing people to
to of course have the ability to
transact with each other with
cryptocurrency in a non-centralized way
what venezuela and russia have been
developing is literally track trace and
database surveillance correct coins uh
what el salvador has been doing is
completely different and it's going to
be a very important case in looking at
how this is implemented on a national
scale and the larger effects that it's
going to have on their markets which is
truly fascinating i was thinking about
going down there and investigating it
and possibly even moving down there
they're creating a tax-free
business zone as well which some people
are saying is going to be the next kind
of singapore who knows if it will if it
won't if bitcoin will crash no one knows
no one could predict that but it
certainly is providing a lot of
opportunities outside of the mainline
establishment system which i think is
absolutely great just an aside some
people are saying twitter is down yeah
i can't i can't check twitter gab is not
let me tell you let me take this
opportunity to tell you gab.com gab is
up and running well so you know with
biden
making all of these statements
them trying to walk it back kamalhair is
doubling down
hopefully this double standard is is a
big smack in the face figuratively to a
lot of people
among many other things among the cove
lockdowns and the vaccine passports and
and all of that stuff
i just i i don't i don't know if i
should be as hopeful that people pay
attention because
when a good example is when lauren
beaubert tweeted that biden said
trinidad shabbat of pressure she said
biden never you know fulfilled his
promise on trinidad shabbat pressure
the left's response was her brain broke
what is she trying to say
because they don't actually listen to
what joe biden says so if joe biden
comes out and says this they probably
did not hear it only we did because
we're the ones paying attention so you
have people in this country who don't
pay attention to what's going on and
then go vote and then you have people
who do pay attention and they're called
conspiracy theorists thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time